in the last video we talked about amino
acids that were nonpolar in this video
we're going to continue our talking of
amino acids and talk about the polar
ones in the last video like I mentioned
we talked about nonpolar ones and there
were nine nonpolar amino acids well the
rest are polar so there have to be
eleven so there are eleven polar amino
acids that we're going to talk about now
we're gonna do the same thing we're
going to talk about their their names
their their abbreviations their
structures and fun facts associated with
them excuse me
so let's just get right to it so polar I
mean Oh acids are a little bit different
than then nonpolar ones in that they're
subdivided into different categories
within polar there are polar neutral
amino acids oops let make that in a
different color so there are polar
neutral of which there are six there are
actually let me make myself a little bit
more space to draw those neutral ones so
there are polar acidic of which there
are two and then there are polar basic
which there are three right for a total
of eleven six plus two x three is eleven
total so let's let's get right to it and
start drawing these ones out okay so for
the polar neutral ones and the first one
I'm going to draw is looks like this
remember the carboxyl group up at the
top alpha carboxyl and then alpha oops
oh goodness
sorry about that I'm going to put an H
there okay the Alpha amino group the
hydrogen and then the R
so this first our group looks like this
now with ch2 and then C with an amine in
a group and a carbonyl group okay
this amino acid is called asparagine so
that's an I in there okay and a spirit
gene it's three-letter abbreviation is a
SN okay and it's a one letter code is n
now it's not ASP will actually gets the
one there actually is an amino acid that
starts with an ASP oceany that also
starts with an ASP and it's three-letter
code as ASP that's actually called
aspartate or aspartic acid which will
draw here in just a moment
this is asparagine okay asparagine looks
a lot like this next amino acid that
when I draw which looks like this and
again I'm going to do the same thing I
did in the last video where I'm not
going to draw these three groups here
it's sort of implied that they're going
to be there although the correct drawing
would include all those different
substituents the next one looks like it
looks pretty much identical to
asparagine the only difference is that
there's one more ch2 group so there's
still that this group here oops okay
this is called glutamine glutamine
three-letter code also ends in an end
just like asparagine so except that's
gln and it's one letter code is Q right
because G has already been taken by
glycine so everything about it a Q kind
of looks like a G almost know if that's
helpful but I go to sort of think about
it that way okay
both of these amino acids have this
particular function
a group here and that is called an amide
okay so these are these both have a mite
or amid functional groups those groups
are not ionizable okay ionizable not
ionizable they can not be turned to diet
they cannot be protonated or
deprotonated at all okay it's important
to keep that in mind for those two okay
so let's draw a few more of the polar
neutral ones okay so this next one will
look like this
it'll just have a ch2 group and an O H
excuse me again that's called serine se
RI any three-letter code is SCR one
letter code is s and that's it okay now
the next one and the reason why I
haven't mentioned any particular fun
facts about this one yet because I want
to write a collective fun fact about a
few that are related to serine much like
I did here with asparagine and glutamine
there they both have the amide groups so
I sort of associated in both of that but
particular little characteristic there
so serine I'm going to write out this
next one this is as a ch2 and a phenyl
group so so far that would be
phenylalanine but then we're going to
top tech on this little Oh H at the end
here and then what we get is tyrosine
okay now tyrosine is T Y R and it's one
letter code is why
okay notice these both have OHS which is
what I'm getting at here in just a
moment as far as the fun facts notice
though that that tyrosine has this
benzene ring right so that is aromatic
okay one more one more of these amino
acids so that's for so far there are two
more that we want to draw the next one
also that also has an O age group is
looks like this as a CH and then an O H
and a ch3 this thing scroll down just a
bit
make some more room this is called
threonine threonine it's it's
three-letter code is thr so there we go
back to the the first three letters it's
one letter code is T so that's why
tyrosine and tryptophan don't have T
right because threonine took it so they
had to get specific ones to them we're
gonna talk about tryptophan but tyrosine
here as a why tyrosine has a Y in it
that could sort of make sense um anyway
so why did I write these three like this
the reason why is because they all have
an OHA
right a hydroxyl group in their side
chain and the reason why that's
important is because all three of these
get my number them 1 2 & 3 okay I guess
I might as well number those 4 and 5 and
just them so I do it now
even though I wrote them first 1 2 & 3
oops write it here 1 2 & 3 can all be
phosphorylated in proteins why is that
important okay first of all they cannot
be phosphorylated in their proteins due
to having that hydroxyl group okay the
hydroxyl group is the group that
actually gets phosphorylated a phosphate
group gets replaces that hydroxyl group
and the reason why that's important is
that is important in regulating protein
activity and we'll talk about this of
this idea in future videos regulation of
protein activity okay sometimes false
for relating a protein could activate it
sometimes phosphorylating a protein
could deactivate it sometimes and
vice-versa for actually both of those it
sort of depends on the protein itself
but the whole idea is that
phosphorylating a an amino acid residue
of one of these three amino acid
residues on our protein alters its
structure and something that we learn in
biology biochemistry and science in
general is that structure determines
function if we alter the structure or
protein chances are we're gonna alter
its function so a phosphorylating a
protein could make it more active less
active or or totally inactive or
completely active whatever it may be so
um that's it's important to keep that
that in mind for these three different
amino acids so that's five of the six
polar neutral ones which are this last
one down here and the last one looks
like this okay it looks like serine
except instead of an O age group it has
an SH group actually before I continue
on with this one I wanted to mention if
you want one last fun fact about
threonine and that's a that also has
this has two chiral centers I forgot to
mention that I'm sorry has two chiral
centers right this here and this here
right because they both have four
different attachments
so anyway sorry about that back to this
one this last one here this one is
called cysteine and this is a very
important amino acid it's one that you
should be very afraid very very familiar
with it's a pretty simple structure but
it's a very important amino acid
it's three-letter code is CYS and it's
one letter code is C last in the last
video we mentioned that we mentioned
methionine as being one of the two
sulfur-containing amino acids
well cysteine is is the other one right
so I guess I should write two of two
sulphur containing amino acids right
and this 8sh group is called a file ok
and what ends up happening is it this
the style group if it's next to another
file group it can form disulfide bonds
or disulfide bridges that's very very
important ok disulfide bonds also called
disulfide bridges ok and the reason why
that's so important it we'll talk about
shortly
maybe not in this video obviously but in
a future video disulfide bonds are
covalent bonds just to give you a quick
idea of how they look they kind of look
like this if there's - if you imagine -
SH as being next to each other right
there's an SH there and SH here what
happens if they if they come together
they can form if those hydrogen's are go
away and I'll talk more about exactly
how this happens we can form a covalent
bond between the two sulfur's and that
actually is that i self-id bond are they
the disulfide bridge so that we'll talk
about that and how it affects the
protein structure and why it's important
all that sort of stuff later but uh I
just wanted you to be familiar with
these ideas but keep in mind assisting
is very very important to me know what I
mean I asked it to to remember and to be
familiar with ok so that's all the the
the polar neutral ones so I guess I
should put six right here right so
that's
total let's talk about the acidic and
basic ones now scroll right back up okay
so let me separate these really quickly
so we don't get too confused okay
so polar acidic now the polar acidic
ones the they're going to have side
chains right that have an acidic
functional group specifically a
carboxylic acid functional group right
so these ones here oops I don't want to
put that in white
I'm dreaded in green so these polar
acidic ones they're actually going to
look very very similar to asparagine and
glutamine so the only difference is that
instead of having a mcgroove or a my
groups they're going to have a
carboxylic acid groups so asparagine had
1 CH 2 and then that amide group right
the difference here in that instead of
not having an avid we're going to have a
carboxylic acid right and a carboxylic
acid at a neutral pH draw silic acids
typically have pH Azure should be PKS
that are pretty low and they're acidic
right so at a neutral pH they will
likely donate their proton exists in
their conjugate base form like this
right so this is actually a sparked
eight this amino acid is called a
sparked eight also called the sparta
Cassatt so i'm going to write here
aspartate okay because that's the way I
drew it in write ASP which is also and
it's one letter code is a is D okay it's
also called aspartic acid now the reason
why I wrote aspartate first is because
it's in its conjugate base form right so
because it's in its conjugate base form
it carries that that eighth name it's
the it's the the conjugate base that's
that we're talking about here right if
this this portion here was protonated it
would be considered osmotic acid
although like I mean
the technicalities are not really too
important but in case you're wondering
why there are two names that's the
reason so notice that at a pH of seven
right again I'm writing all drawing all
of these at a pH of seven the polar
acidic ones will carry a negative charge
okay at a pH of seven and this is why
because this negative and this positive
balance out to zero and then all you're
left with is this negative charge here
okay so overall it carries a minus one
charge now the other the other polar
acidic amino acid looks a little bit
like glutamine it's very much the same
way as a spartina or aspartic acid
worked it looks exactly like glutamine
except instead of an amide group it has
a carboxylic acid group so ch2 ch2 and
then see w10
minus there and then we have glutamate
so glutamate right or glutamic acid okay
this one is Glu it's also e on an ox I
just remember I remember Glu prove it
glutamate
many gate this one also carries an
overall negative charge that amino acid
okay so the way I remember these
structures and these structures here is
just I remember the similarities between
them oftentimes when it comes to
memorizing all these different amino
acids a little facts about them their
structures and names all that sort of
stuff a lot of the times it helps to
sort of group things based on
similarities so knowing that how you
know how these two polar acidic ones are
related sort of to these polar neutral
ones in structure that that can kind of
help you remember what the structures
are like okay but that's pretty much it
for the polar acidic one so let's talk
about the polar basic ones so the polar
basic ones okay now the polar basic ones
they will typically carry a
positive charge at a neutral pH okay
there is a slight exception now I'll go
over that but you can imagine that if if
these polar basic ones have side chains
with amino groups amino groups when
they're protonated carry a positive
charge right so if we have an alpha
carboxyl group an alpha amino group
right those charges are going to balance
out if we're left with a positive charge
I mean no group that's charged
we're going to have a positive charge so
let me let me draw out the three polar
basic ones the way I kind of remember
the polar basic ones is I I think of I
think how so how is a pretty basic name
okay basic name so the three the three
basic amino acids are histidine arginine
and lysine okay so if that helps just
just to help you remember the three
basic amino acids now these aren't the
one letter codes is to just help you to
remember the names anyway let's draw the
first one being histidine so histidine
will look like this at a pH of seven now
I know I mentioned this positive charge
here but I'm going to draw this first
one as an exception so histidine looks
like this right it's a its side chain
looks like this it has a ch2 and then
it's connected to this little ring
structure here and this ring has a
double bond here and a double bond here
and n here and an N here the end that
does not have the double bond carries
just an H and that's all it's going to
carry however this one over here this
end it's double bound has is that is
involved in that double bond can be
protonated now at a pH of seven it isn't
protonated why the reason why is because
this group has a PKA has a PKA
of approximately six right so if it's
PKA is lower than than seven then that
means it's going to act as an acid at
that pH and donate its proton to the
environment so it won't be protonated
however if you lower the pH enough this
group will be protonated and it will
look like this so I'm going to put lower
pH okay if you lower the pH then you'll
get that group to be protonated and it
will look instead of like that it will
look like this okay so not the ch2 and
this NH will still be the same the only
difference that this n will now be
protonated and carry that positive
charge there okay so these are both
histidine riders at different PHS now
typically basic the basic functional
groups will carry a positive charge and
that that holds true for our gene a
lysine histidine is just a little bit
weird this group here this actual
functional group here is is called an
amid isel group
okay so I'll write that in purple so
this is an amid izl group amid izl group
and that's actually the group that has
the pKa of six okay so that's histidine
let's draw arginine lysine so arginine
looks like this
arginine has 3 CH 2 s and then an NH and
then another carbon and then let me
scroll down just a tad sway a little bit
of room here and then this carbon has an
NH 2 and this carbon has an nh-2 as well
but this n has four bonds to
so it's going to be protonated okay so
this here is arginine okay so arginine
are loose
sorry arginine okay and arginines
three-letter code is a arg and it's one
letter code is our so our Jeanine like I
think like a pirate
oh I'd forgot to write histidines name
and three-letter code in my letter code
so histidine is expelled like this sorry
histidine three letter code is hiss and
then it's one letter code is H sorry
about that I should have written that
earlier okay so um this is arginine
notice again here the the double bonded
nitrogen is the nitrogen that can be
protonated the pKa of this functional
group is actually very very high so I
think it's a twelve twelve and a half
close to close to twelve and a half this
group here is called a guanidine o group
okay so it's a guanidine o group and
it's very very basic right it's so basic
it has a pKa of like I said around 12.5
okay so that's that's so that's
histidine arginine is one more is lysine
is the last folder basic amino acid
let's draw that finish this off so the
last polar basic one would look like
this my that carboxyl group amino group
hydrogen and then lysine has 4 CH 2 s a
friend of wine once once told me that
lysine was the amino acid involved in
Jurassic Park I don't know they talked
about it in Jurassic Park film and one
of the ways is that helped them remember
the structure of
of lysine was that a lot of the
dinosaurs that were talked about had
four legs right so four-legged dinosaurs
one two three four ch2 so silly but if
it helps you remember the structure then
by all means use it right so as I
mentioned this is this is lysine and
lysine is three letter code is ly s and
it's one letter code is K okay and
that's because leucine already took VL
so again so notice that between or
shooting me for arginine and lysine they
both carry overall positive charges
right so here for lysine we have the
negative here the positive here and the
positive here so it's an overall +1
charge and in arginine we have a
negative plus and then plus here so
that's an overall positive charge as
well so that's a pretty much it for the
polar amino acids so it's again keep in
mind these differences these subtleties
and it'll be very very important in the
future to to understand what these amino
acids will look like given a particular
pH so if you know the pka's of the side
chains or all of all the different
ionizable groups right so the polar
acidic and polar basic amino acids have
groups that are ionizable right the
polar acidic ones can either exist in a
protonated form that's the protonated
form that's neutral or then the base
form like this which is negatively
charged and the polar basic ones if
they're protonated they'll be positive
and if they're deprotonated they'll be
neutral so it's very very important to
understand how we can use the
henderson-hasselbalch equation which we
talked about earlier to help us
understand how these different amino
acids will look at a particular pH if we
know the pKa is of all the ionizable
groups including the Alpha amino and
carboxyl group and the sidechain PKA if
the sidechain has a PKA all right so I
hope that was helpful and that's pretty
much all the amino acids see you next
time